That Time the US Accidentally Nuked Britain's
First Satellite
When it comes to nations with a long and rich
history of space travel and exploration, Britain
isn’t normally a country that comes to most
people’s minds.
However, they were the third country in the
world to operate a satellite in orbit.
It’s just a shame America ended up accidentally
killing it just a few months later…
The satellite in question was the Ariel-1,
which was developed as a joint-venture between
the United States and Britain, with Britain
designing and building the core systems of
the satellite and NASA launching it into orbit
via a Thor-Delta rocket.
The UK scientists first proposed the idea
for Ariel-1 to NASA in 1959 after NASA made
an offer to help fly the scientific equipment
of other nations into space.
Due to the close relationship between the
two countries, details were easily and quickly
worked out and by the following year, scientists
in the UK were given the go ahead to start
creating the instrumentation needed, while
engineers in the US began work on the satellite
that would house the equipment.
On the 26th of April, 1962, the first international
space effort ever was launched into space
and Britain was operating its first satellite.
According to NASA, the instruments aboard
Ariel-1 were intended to help “contribute
to the current knowledge of the ionosphere”
and its relationship with the Sun.
More specifically, scientists were curious
about how the ionosphere, a part of the Earth’s
atmosphere made of particles charged by radiation
from the Sun, worked.
(For more on the ionosphere, see: Why Do Radio
Signals Travel Farther at Night than in the
Day?)
To accomplish its mission, Ariel-1 was loaded
with a tape recorder for storing collected
data, a device designed to measure solar radiation,
and several instruments used to measure how
the various particles in the ionosphere reacted
and changed in response to external stimuli
from the cosmos, most notably the Sun.
On July 9, 1962, mere weeks after Ariel-1
was put into orbit and had successfully begun
transmitting data about the ionosphere back
to Earth, British scientists were shocked
when the sensors aboard Ariel-1 designed to
measure radiation levels suddenly began to
give wildly high readings.
Initially, they assumed that the satellite’s
instruments had failed or were otherwise just
malfunctioning.
Starfish Explosion as Seen from Honolulu
As it turned out, as Ariel-1 was happily free-falling
around the Earth, the US military had decided
to detonate an experimental 1.4 megaton nuclear
weapon named Starfish-Prime in the upper atmosphere
as part of Project Fish Bowl.
The explosion, which happened on the other
side of the planet to Ariel-1, sent a wave
of additional radiation around the Earth that
ultimately damaged some of the systems on
Ariel-1, particularly its solar panels, ultimately
killing it and about 1/3 of the rest of the
satellites in low-Earth orbit at the time.
This famously included the Telstar satellite,
which was the first commercial communication
relay satellite designed to transmit signals
across the Atlantic.
The Telstar actually wasn’t in orbit at
the time of the explosion, being put there
the day after the Starfish-Prime detonation.
However, the additional radiation created
by the explosion took years to dissipate and
was not anticipated by the designers of this
particular satellite.
The immediate result being the degradation
of Telstar’s systems, particularly the failure
of several transistors in the command system,
causing it to stop working just a few months
after being placed in orbit.
As to the purpose of the Starfish-Prime explosion,
according to James Fleming, a history professor
who combed through previously top-secret files
and recordings concerning the blast, the U.S.
military were working with scientist James
Van Allen to see if nuclear explosions could
influence the existing belts of radiation
around the Earth.
Van Allen apparently started working with
the military to launch nukes into these belts
the very same day he announced to the world
that he’d discovered the belts, now known
as the Van Allen radiation belts.
Flemming noted of this,
“This is the first occasion I’ve ever
discovered where someone discovered something
and immediately decided
to blow it up.”
He forgot to mention the obligatory, FOR SCIENCE!!!